what's up dude not much my brother happy
Monday to you bro
you still got no shoelaces yeah you know
that's how I rock it sometimes cuz I'm
like I'm like I'm gonna put these shoes
on by Fluevog and they're gonna feel
good
here's the private do they come with
them yeah now they don't they they came
like this you know I don't that I wear
because they're just comfortable you
know what you know what the secret is
you know what the problem with me is I
got a little nerve in my in my toe and
if my feet are scrunched up in a certain
way every time I walk that nervous dude
aw it hurts it yep so I gotta wear tight
shoes if there I get wide feet bro yeah
they're tight like I get these news are
awesome he said to me didn't try them on
can't wear the new easy it's
disappointing to spread they're too
tight at the front no problem got a gym
so can't have what they call them Roach
killers
there's a roach in the corner like in
the corner of the room and you you used
it point a party to all like yeah see
you call them Roach killers because you
kicked that that rotates into the corner
and kill it cuz you got old school
because your butt can get into the
corner crap you know in the corner get
room yeah I got it get your Roach
killers I see a roach kickin kickin yeah
how was your dinner on Saturday dude it
was and go man bit epic will not be
honest don't don't say epic though huh
but but I should well I'll tell ya best
way to describe it is this as my boy
Colin who's a listener of the podcast
Connor Connor
sick chef sick chef cooking sure
everybody I invite comes shows up except
for you thank you and it's like 10
people or out of 10 dues I've known for
a long time real talk first okay real
talk at one point my buddy goes have you
noticed that nobody it's been three
hours and nobody's looked at their phone
once that's when you're having a real
conversation we guys are older to what
oh really oh no in fact Herman rents
who's a comic who's like he's 30 he said
that but it was really interesting it
was like it was like and I put it just a
bunch of people and did you guys go goes
is this the best night ever and then hug
yeah I said is this whoa no we got a
little drunk is this the best night ever
guys that bad last time someone looked
at their phone I don't want shut the
[ __ ] up I'll take that had some veterans
there who were drinking tequila and
and then Frank and I got riled up
because they were they were you know
badass Marines and they were drunk and
we were having a laugh with them who
else who else came that I know um Frank
Jeff Foley you don't know Jeff and Jeff
one of the best yeah it was a really
good night
who else dude Jed meant off you don't
think you know my friend I was 18
Herrmann you know Herrmann rents told
play d1 basketball stand-up comic funny
guys start now yeah
oh court court Courtland who did art who
did the ball I like him yeah great kind
of seen him yep and I'm trying to think
I'm drawing of our boys like the Rudy
Reyes oh uh no Sasso it was in Canada he
would have come but he couldn't make it
no den Julia was somewhere else Santino
was gone I invited a misting group
couldn't make it
well it's very eclectic group yeah when
you put people from different
backgrounds you got to combat decorated
Marines you got a designer where you
know them from through Frank Rudy Reyes
and his buddy who was a Marine came over
and they're both great and but when you
mix what I love to do is I'll take all
different people and put them together
in a room and you're eating food and
talking and some cool [ __ ] happens just
a screwin April I don't think you mean
conversations I mean I mean nudity and I
mean I mean some light wrestling I just
laughs slaps and deep conversations what
kind of food was it dude
lamb had ourselves some sea bass some
lamb chops little lamb chop yeah we had
some very good vegetables we had some
cheese gotta have some cheese and a lot
of excellent wine oh you boys yes boy
you boys before watching remember we
watched the fights we watched the canal
fight which we can get into though watch
the we watch the I mean the 3-round is
quite a fight yeah if I what else was
there like let it go
well the whole point of that fight I
think was to get us to download that app
I had problems that can undo a task the
[ __ ] all Rayna that turns out in the
zone well their app itself is raid I
don't know the app itself called does
the zone da Zn is that one yeah dis
sound its
you guys illegally no it's the black
thing right yeah you know I got a
problem no I got it for free on apple TV
don't leave no I know it's just like
that one that one whatever that is
that's de zona he says radar though I
was thinking up on our radar
no it's let's say watched UFC
pay-per-views oh there it is rated
stream illegally streaming all those
like events including UFC so it's fine
dude I see how you make that up just
know I had found my smart TV I sure you
load that app with Frank took us forever
and then we watched it hot but real
quick how difficult is it to get the
disowned [ __ ] going it took us an hour
you did it I was 45 minutes in I want
you up [ __ ] Frank Frank it blank Franco
gon [ __ ] cuz I could happen to put my
name my email my password on the
password ask for five characters hello
did you see that what [ __ ] bass board
needs five K you know what a character
is dollar sign so I was like I didn't
remember what the character I was like I
don't know I put in five out and I turn
round every way ting for me you damn it
you know what this man is fighting me
over in five rounds ill wait so how did
you know that but I thought again
champion he's taller first of all can I
ask you a question as a boxing guy he
must have gone in there going oh I'm
gonna take a paycheck and I'm gonna lose
because if this is all about the zone
and I'm a No he stood he had his hands
he said I'm gonna go toe-to-toe with
with Canelo bigger guy why don't you use
your jab and keep him away
what night would necklace style he's a
brawler he's a bigger dude he's a
brother he so he wouldn't so after all
that time he wouldn't mean some guys
just don't it's not their style man
Jesus it back when you guys hit mitts
and [ __ ] and go oh you should have just
Japanese footwork style hold on I admit
I do
good work Joe fuller job hey Brian Frank
both of you doesn't matter same time
jump in there and footwork in jab Canelo
Alvarez I mean III would keep by I'm
let me put it this way no look I keep
him I keep ma Q piling up yeah I know
yeah I know but yeah the zone set was I
just want you not [ __ ] it just [ __ ] it
it's just too much effort it's all I can
just click on it by the way by the way a
complete massacre out I'm out man Bailey
streamed it did you have Kevin Lee over
Iaquinta and I thought well no no I
thought the judge got it right but I
originally I paid Kevin know what I mean
is what I mean is originally is I
because Kevin Lee was winning in the
beginning yeah then I Quentin comes back
with those look it was just crazy little
fury
did you see old caddy cat's picture on
Instagram sure didn't dressed up with
the holiday party cat I mean yep I went
to my company's corporate holiday party
so I got dressed up for a night that's
[ __ ] hilarious
that's hilarious I approved right I
approve bravo Bravo sister um was it a
big party where was it at cat yeah it
was at the california club downtown
really fancy I like your keuken I saw
the wallpaper I didn't know whether or
not to be offended or not I'm kind of
into it though this is the new company
yep the new company were people nice to
you or people kind of weird no everyone
was nice it's usually the residents
creepy guys are creepy
some of them creepy some of them with
very strong Asian fetishes sure uh so at
least I have the option of marry rich
but yeah most of them are really nice
that's cool yeah I did you bring your
boy your man there mm-hmm
no you didn't bring him you don't want
to go it was um he's like yo sorry nice
video game night you just don't want to
go didn't want to go also it's it's like
workers only no spouses yeah that's
[ __ ] up those bosses no spouse you
should get a plus well I mean you forced
to go by yourself yeah it so basically
it's just me and my coworkers him that's
kind of interesting
it was nice free food free booze good
food yeah good food good sea bass and
filet mignon we're doing a little
company party here let's go play
tomorrow night yeah we are
we're gonna do the same policy no
friends no friends
no friends please Brian Brennan chin and
cat that's squad that's the squad have
you ever had you ever gone out with
somebody because you kind of had to and
then you you mean like a day dude no
just like you're out with some people
and you're like and then you season it
in with somebody you'd rather hang out
no yeah we're supposed to have dinner
yeah well I've dinner then you're like
I'm gonna bring my friend there's a
buffer oh the worst [ __ ] I'm gonna die
the worst I went and saw a mall Santa
Brian you know how anti malson I am I
went Bob not by choice my girls sign
means I go up for it when you have kids
you're standing that line to meet mall
Santa and that's appalling
yes their lines plumb there instead like
they went to the Grove obviously had an
appointment but when we get there
this is what bothered me tight you know
tiger loves everybody's loving kids so
he hugs them and it's like oh good boys
I groped his back I'm like easy Santa
easy and then he goes oh he kept calling
him sweetie and then I was a cake boy
though ha so sweetie doesn't work you
know it's like it calms it rubbed me the
wrong way
you've got off sweetie yeah that's a guy
that's so much so you said oh that is so
interesti said cuz I had a guy call my
son sweetheart and he kept call him
sweetheart and it was like you know I
mean they're so cute and they're so
little at that age but my friend's
father I said oh I was in college and I
and I said I was I never forgot this I
said you know I drove faster so I get
there and he said honey listen don't
ever speed like that on and I'll tell
you why he called me honey twice and he
just cared about me didn't want me to
speaks didn't want me to die but his
older man but he's like honey you don't
have to swim I was and I was like I'm um
I'm 19 sir 20
you just can't call me [ __ ] look like
when I get my Starbucks and this lady
sometimes in the more when I go there
she does anything else sweetie I'm like
well I'm older than you so don't call me
sweetie though yeah I don't mind that I
don't mind if it's a it's a gallon
they're really young I feel like like
she's like she looks like kills Jukes
younger that can but white yeah and
she's like sweetie I'm like I had a cow
call me Dollface she goes all right doll
face is that all like this hey man I'm
not a doll face that's all I got big
dummy anything else like well no man my
buddy my buddy Jimmy Burke likes to do
that [ __ ] to me I'll be will be at
dinner and I'll be like a waiter or
we'll be around some guys and he'll
he'll [ __ ] him put his arm
he'll just put his arm gently around the
small my waist already a problem and he
goes sweetheart you want a drink
sweet okay you want to drink bed like
that I'm like dude don't start with that
[ __ ]
honey cake is what's up honey what's
going on he keeps his arm there and I go
get your [ __ ] on you got these guys
over here get your arm off me there's
also the duty calls your girl or any
girl babe yeah baby and anything like
well it's not your baby though is it
right your babe bro your baby girl so
let's not call her babe Hey Baby you
want some dude like mMmmm not
comfortable now yeah that's a little
weird
you're them all saying that strange dude
yeah I just don't trust a man I just
don't get that vibe mall Santa they
don't get that one sweetie
he's so cute that I would calm sweetie
he's cute as [ __ ] when you're a little
like that doesn't matter but yeah super
cute and I [ __ ] up don't don't speed
honey you know why that's funny it's
you're not gonna get there any faster on
I promise I I get all crunk take my son
as spider-man so I drove to target eight
in the morning after I worked out drove
at 8:00 in the morning I got all these
spider-man toys and I saw one toy that
had just had like all the characters
like well yeah I want that too these two
stupid ones so I grabbed it then I get
home [ __ ] nightmare
it was like and I don't know why they
put him with the toys for kids it was
like these collector items were the
characters and these concealed glass
cases where you can't play with him get
him out and then you're supposed to like
stack him but it's for grown men like
it's like stacking my collect
collectibles by giving my son he's like
all right man and he's trying to stack
him to him frustrating if I tried sawing
a thing
[ __ ] night well Taran kill him I
think we probably talked about it on the
podcast but I go to his house for
Thanksgiving and he's like so my office
is the exact opposite well your office
will be
and he knows I'm gonna make fun of them
because I'm half a bully and I walk in
he's got all the Star Wars collectors
items memorabilia in the packaging I'm
like dude you are a nerd he collects
them
yeah he's unabashedly proud he's like
yeah whatever collects it all I'm like
you a [ __ ] nerd I wanted I started
shoving him around
you don't really collected anything like
that I don't I want to make I can get
down as a kid I can like like rocks and
knives in sex and no no no baseball card
trading cards no I didn't do that [ __ ]
really raw [ __ ] off
yeah the read that dumbest kid in the
world or rod hey Brian here's a gray
rock bro dude tell me that's from the
yard up there is another than my clams
and things like all hands and have been
a real thrill I'm opening up to you
right now yeah clam over everybody get
the [ __ ] in my face I got a bo Jackson
really far dork
come on I'll trade you listen I got two
clams nah I'll trade you two clamps for
that Steve Young favorite desert clams
they were the Tesla Babe Ruth the guard
no I fossils and and like arrowheads
okay well they just three arrowheads and
one clam for that junior sail rookie but
absolutely not Brian you're that kid man
and Ron knives that collected nine oh
wow
we the biggest loser agent hey man did
you open it up to you did you collect
anything yeah now that you say I don't
remember you [ __ ] [ __ ] all clams nice
human fingers in here what did you
collect besides just doll heads what
would you collect collect now thank you
weren't into anything collecting like
what happened like what was your [ __ ] as
a kid like RC cars would you like you're
the ones we could take the top off and
then mess my belt everything yeah
Wheaton me my brother get down that [ __ ]
model airplanes Jedi me my dad and my
brother would go to that we do this
every three or four weeks we would drive
to cope our hobbies or yeah cope our
hobbies
we'd pick out either car or plane then
we go next door to Dunkin Donuts I'd get
a vanilla filled chocolate donut and Jay
would get a chocolate glazed
and then we'd go home and we'd make the
models see every 3-4 weeks I just didn't
have the patience to a [ __ ] model
airplane that's how I learned about cars
really oh yeah I mean that's so cool cuz
I would buy it and put a Python [ __ ]
this is taking too long man yeah that's
so interesting you took you at your you
had you had the patience to push it
together with IJ really did it I'd like
help them out all the time but I'll take
it from here
I'll prime everything and painted for
you in my acting class one time this kid
did the most powerful you had to have an
activity and be emotional through it in
other words he liked it so acting is
doing right it's like psychology and the
behavior that would be the idea and this
kid [ __ ] is putting together this
model airplane pretending you're saying
he's putting it together and he's they
got a tear down his eye and the teacher
stops and goes what are you doing well
what's going on in your head what cuz if
he had to be anything and he goes well
the last time I saw my father before he
took off he helped me make up a model
airplane and this is the same airplane
that I put together with him and he did
it and then teacher goes I want you to
keep going dude the whole [ __ ] class
ride bro I he told me I'm not emotional
host I was like round of applause round
of applause what happened is it was the
greatest thing airplane
his father yeah his father passed away
and then his father's join up to that
and then after that I go dude that was
so [ __ ] incredible I'm sorry that
your dad left I guess my dad didn't
leave my dad and I have a great
relationship like that big [ __ ]
he pulled the wool over did you collect
anything catrien anything no no how old
are you 23
you're young yeah so what would you like
23 that's like what was big when you're
a kid 23 so that's Backstreet Boys NSYNC
and think best shoot Britney Spears nice
piers
what about that of the the digital pet
oh my god she knows I was never into
that okay no there's another name for
right we just did a tamagotchi episode
on schooled that's always cool yeah what
else I don't know I don't remember
pretty
9 type in ninety eight ninety toys Jen
you really didn't collect anything you
or your urban was the Furby
remember when rock pet rocks were a big
thing I never got into that but of
course she didn't cat no one [ __ ]
dude no I got into it well I J but way
before was this no idea I'm not opening
up to you anymore I knew a girl we used
to collect rocks and then make it her
pet rock cuz she wasn't allowed to have
like a dog and she for Glee eyes on them
she could have sold that for a million
dollars hogs see I did pause for a
little bit beanie babies that's that's
past your time though right a little
before my time
yeah Skippy get the [ __ ] out my yo-yos
slinkys Furby Stretch Armstrong that's
Oliver be my friend invented Oh easy
bags I used to play with that all the
time
my buddy Roger cheesy bakes been around
forever
yeah easy babe troll dolls past your
time couch patch past your time talk
talk to boy past your time oh now I
remember transformers and Gobots I would
collect those clothes transformers and
go Babbage patch remember Cabbage Patch
yeah one for $1,000 I love [ __ ] orbits
pal kids that was my [ __ ] what's that
hey man don't make fun of me I was older
bringing uh typing big wheels in 90s
really know I had that in the eighties
get the [ __ ] out of there and I would
ride ride that thing so hard the
[ __ ] we on the front cracked it
always split remember these it was
always like it was always like add up
like Adam Bomb there you got math hey
max trippy Debbie like it was like
pretty nasty very very nasty what are
they breezy Betty and [ __ ] legs
dolls young for the other just car
trading cards but they're pretty vulgar
keep going to like 18 cards what the
[ __ ] does that mean why would you have
trading cards you're a dork no nice try
real all the kids are doing this car but
no games once you give me some [ __ ]
raw but what would you do trade them
what do you mean you collected them do
that there's like a ton of them what a
bunch of horseshit
yeah you wish green me a rock [ __ ] hey
do me a favor go give me a clamp
Donald Trump Donald dumped these are
newer ones that yeah like that
I remember stuff like that Zach yeah
they're disgusting and that no this
rings a bell for you guys huh
yeah I did pogs trend I'm video games no
video games cat no not really I like to
watching people play video games
it's a huge business but I cannot watch
me I get so bored watching other people
like video games
Oh Mike you make tons of money you yeah
will you watch my [ __ ] in video games
November I don't can I go in the nose
all the console I would imagine it that
this is a virtual reality [ __ ] mmm now
it's gonna be a whole different thing
that's crazy
you wear those goggles yeah I mean have
you seen some of the things like there's
some of the physical ones where they
have a way to go
they've always to go aways yeah oh ways
I'm buying the new Oh Ellie deed Sony TV
it's supposed to be like I went I looked
at TV 65-inch it when it looked at all
these TVs I went and saw that one I was
like well everything sucks compared to
this that's the problem is they show you
the really good one and then you're like
oh no this sound is so much better
yes it's it's the best you can buy
that's nice mm-hmm aids with TVs
remember when I was a kid flat screens
were so expensive like 60 inches you're
at 12 13 grand mm-hmm I get your [ __ ]
70 inch screen now for 800 bucks it's
crazy that's great and super thin yep
so with Sonia Bronx teens just go down
in price big time prior to discount so
gorgeous it's a hell of a TV right there
you got a TV right chanting we got your
TV right but no the ones I ordered for
whatever reason they're all damaged I
did go broke yeah who's broke they've
had like a freakin a fist inside it like
someone actually punched this screen cuz
I was like I just stopped already after
a while I had two of them so you suck
returned broken TVs now know how to
return them and I actually under paying
money out of my pocket to return them
damn that's [ __ ] up yeah you get this
all good I don't need a TV you have a
nice TV at your crib yeah I have a
flat-screen don't use it right watch
them who doesn't have a Fleshman those
ya know in this day and age I don't know
anyone
many of the bubble TV now like what Liv
gets I go I have the wooden one on the
floor with the antenna fix ya fix the
bunny ears man god I'll never forget we
had a baby I thought was when their kids
we had doing this big wooden TVs that
had like the cloth speakers on the side
and we would always watch movies and
we'd always watch it every Friday night
we'd watch like Robocop or some [ __ ]
like that or bloodsport and we're all we
did BJ of me and my dad be in the middle
we'd sit down this week like this big
like Paulo that all three of us could
fit on and they were sitting there and
it smelled like pure [ __ ] I mean this
felt horrible my dad does not play you
know my daddy goes who farted and I look
at Jam like I definitely did it my dad's
like who the [ __ ] farted and I'm like I
have no idea it smells I mean it shows
off all and my that's like CFC guys who
farted and he's like getting mad and
Jaycee I swear to god it wasn't me
I was like dad it wasn't me but I was
like well someone did it like you know
upset stops the movie the COO farted
like that and because it was like he was
[ __ ] destroying the house are you so
bad and then my dad goes well
something's up so I can starts walking
around and we had this cat dad let it go
I know for sure relax if someone did
relax but neither one was dead we had
this cat we called it mama cat kind of
super creative she was the mom of the
other cats this cat called mama cat
lives the tabby decided you know what I
don't like it here took a [ __ ] behind
the TV the size of a so he goes
unbelievable [ __ ] hate these cats I'm
not lying I never saw it cat then from
there on out I don't know what he did
with it I don't know what happened to it
[ __ ] college I come home with this
girl I like so much was so hot and I was
like I couldn't least she's coming back
to my place so of course I'm just like I
forget everything we go at it we start
going at it and we are just in the act
I'm I'm having a sexy me I'm having sex
I'm like a smoke show no protection of
an eye this well
I know and she goes I got snow I go oh
no and she goes something's going on and
I look over and my pitbull his I didn't
walk him because I I was so excited
my dogs I can't hold it he's squatting
and [ __ ] a giant head right on my
for not two feet away stop sir shit's
awesome Donald sounds like oh I gotta
clean this out the whole lot it was the
biggest [ __ ] time today I mean just
weekend it just didn't go well I don't
remember yeah I cleaned it up and did
this this [ __ ] weekend I went like
was something stunk in my house I'm
cleaning my house up and something stunk
I kept looking on the table where the
[ __ ] who shat is the dog farting it was
the plants plants the water and the
plants in there a long time a man that
can smell like [ __ ] rut rocks it's nasty
when that when the plant matter starts
to decompose it was the worse yes dude
animals will [ __ ] your day up and I'm
gonna [ __ ] your damn you know there you
have a dog great chin yeah
at your house my parrot sauce oh so not
yours I'd still got my dog welcome you
walk him on the weekends when I'm there
so you like a you like a stepdad yeah I
kind of think that you have any dogs
cats no cats one pup at the house with
you mm-hm what kind of pup
uh he's this little he's like a terrier
mix like maybe tear your Chihuahua you
post any pictures of him uh no I don't
think I've ever seen each of them he
looks like a rat basically whoo I like
rats I like working line German
Shepherds I'll never had like corgis and
Shepherds best dogs they're so smart
German Shepherds if they're the real
deal if they come from either cohesive
man now she just just one up cat - Wow
Oh mr. Dworkin German Shepherds all
right we'll take these
senior dog I'm working line German
Shepherd Oh
let me show you step I'll show you the
Condor I'm working line German working
line chairman Shepherd don't make me
repeat it let's get some yes yours
escaped oh yeah there you go
put that right there right there right
now those are cool your dog disabled
caught a dog oh those are cool yours
does not look like the couple wolves
couple one yeah sure another thing's
badass yours is not mine is smaller but
she will bite you especially in the face
super friendly you got a good one
yeah she's friend but those those dogs
are no they're great what you're doing
when you got yours but no they are
connected to you there you go Adela's
mean look at that [ __ ] right
there that's my dog run after their dog
does not look like that I'll do it why
is that they have that one leg on them
so when they out cuz so they that's how
they make them pose but also when you
have a slope back dog like that don't
get it
that's bred by the AKC that's a show on
you want to straight back dog they bred
him like you want an athletic straight
back [ __ ] yeah they all doing it
there that's a straight back dog see
that that's how I stand hey there he's
gotta calm down a short withers you know
how I know you're not a tough guy when
you're that into tough dog oh there you
go that's a [ __ ] wolf right there bro
I swear to God when I give my captain
one this guy maybe three imma I posted
it on my Instagram story like a few days
ago I'm gonna take a picture it there's
a Siberian Husky which is the base one
I've ever seen then he also has a pet
wolf straight-up wolf in marvista
it's a wolf it's [ __ ] huge yeah you
just don't worry about him you won't buy
them like do because there's all these
kids yeah here's the problem with wolves
and kids no no he's you yeah huge mint
circular pounds I like [ __ ] like real
wolf I'm gonna take a picture of it it's
a wolf hybrid but but it's still a lot
of wolf so here's a problem with wolf
hybrids that people don't ever talk
about their walls
nope why are they dangerous around kids
they're friendly and they'll be good
family dogs here is whether dangerous
around kids wolf hybrids have very very
high and pronounced backpack dry pipe
accents pack sense
so the everything is packed so you're
the leader of their pack they look at
children
below them in the pack and then they'll
look at children some eyes this
competition in their pack and they'll
take a kid out and people who really
know wolves will tell you no hybrids
they're not safe or otherwise and I
don't give a [ __ ] I know people are
gonna hit me up and go you don't know
listen the evidence that's a hot topic
that thing the thing is look how cool
things that big but it's like a silver
yeah that's a black wolf hybrid I've
seen them yeah and guten this here just
chills I'm like dude you can you put it
in the back they're super friendly kids
I'm like I don't give a [ __ ] if this
thing - super friendly around kids until
their leader is not there until the pack
leaders not better he leaves it not a
good idea I don't care what he said the
guy can tell him a little uneasy I'm
like dude come on man around the kiddos
it's got a very high pack instinct it's
that that instinct is still in it
because it's got a lot of wolf they are
gorgeous though yeah you can't have one
is it not the best watchdogs believe
you're not involves eyedropper Dan I
just wanna if I you another dog is one
good god let's say I'm tell you that's
how big this [ __ ] thing is that
thinks I'm I hope it's there tomorrow
and take a picture Mike what's up now
[ __ ] they are amazing I'm sure they're
gnarly as [ __ ] [ __ ] say wolf around Joe
Rogan he'll talk to about wolves for
seven hours I've read books on you know
someone they're [ __ ] furious animals
yeah they're badass animals I just wanna
I just wanna I don't want a [ __ ]
Ferrari for a dog now I just want to
what like a lab so much you want a
predictable animal an animal were safe
sleeps in his bed I don't need a Navy
SEAL yeah look at that dog growling
that's a wolf right there [ __ ] around
with that thing the thing is that day
when they bite me I'll bite your hand
off that'll bite your hand off yeah it
really will - it'll bite your hand off
you don't see a lot of them if it can
crush an Elk's thigh it's gonna go this
photo show I'm watching that show on
Showtime called the escape of Dannemora
good thing it's a it's one of the best
shows I've seen a lot of times really
some is the true story right but they
were saying how the two prisoners that
escaped they their plan was off see the
girl they're hooking up with they're
just manipulating her to pick him up and
then drive him to West Virginia they
come up with a plan B if she didn't show
so she doesn't show this is all true
stories came out seven years ago so no
spoiler alert you [ __ ] so she doesn't
show right so they have to figure out on
their own you know what they didn't
think in consideration to things well
you're in the upper state you're all
from New York well it's in the summer
but that but they're going through the
woods so yeah I deal with those animals
up there oh the animals in the woods
then also the homeboy on the left in
that picture is the Skinner or on the
right there the skinnier one he's in
shape he's a bit of a beast the dude on
the left is horribly out of shape well
you're hiking jogging running for hours
upon hours so hungry and thirsty and you
break down quick and he said the guy in
the left just started started
complaining like dude [ __ ] this I'm just
gonna I don't I want to die and sooo guy
on the right was like I'm out of here
man you're a [ __ ] I gotta keep going so
he went off on his own home why on the
left
decides to hunker down shut the face
three times son yeah but dude you're
kind of spoiling everything it happened
something we don't you want to watch the
show bro but you don't watch the news
like that watch the show bro stop
spoiling the [ __ ] show you're
recapping in a bad way the great show
that I'd like to watch I don't know hey
tell me you're not gonna watch it you'll
have Showtime yeah yeah I don't watch
shows I wanna show you watch it named
Showtime I just rushed three episodes of
the new narcos you son of a [ __ ] Arcos
that came out three months ago one of
them that's good yeah who's your
favorite character Bob the ex-cop yeah
and don't tell me what happens in that
cuz I'm going to three horse season of
narcos you know why it's the worst
season I mean if you don't care
did you know why guy yeah we have no one
to root for exactly and I went over this
with Todd's guy does it I don't what
dude i text them just it's not the bail
so we also know that we know how it ends
because if there is no ending and out so
this is all a waste of time there's war
on drugs how's it going so how you gonna
say you know how it ends [ __ ] when we
watch the one on Pablo Escobar we know
if he and Dana
yes same with this no I didn't know and
now you gotta tell me about you
literally recap the whole episode god
dammit Brendan well no I do you want me
to tell you what happened no I don't and
nobody else does either it's nothing I'm
not reading the news accounts of escape
I see a show that I want to see and I
want to watch it's a big show [ __ ]
care you watch narcos and if I went dude
publiced know I would you go what
happens in the episode because it's a
it's a story that's been crafted a
[ __ ] spoiler I don't need hey do me a
favor don't recap the show
alright well that's well I saw a
spider-man to tell me that it's a kid
with [ __ ] spider skids you skills
these [ __ ] not the same it's a real
story apologize to everybody
I don't educate yourself they came out
2015 I knew those facts in 2005 every
story though no you don't I do sure
don't because when I ask you things
about it you didn't know dude well whose
uh-oh those two plays yeah oh [ __ ] do
you know who the her husband is spot-on
I mean it looks like the real husband
yeah I saw the real deal my coldly
[ __ ] the way they talked Benicio del
Toro is a hell of an actor oh my god he
doesn't miss he's like Clint Eastwood
he loves the he likes getting into
character oh my you been on some elby's
how about Ben uh yeah Ben Stiller
directed that he's great I think is its
first directing man Josh but he shows a
monster where is he from Mexico
absolutely what a reporter Rican bro
where thought he's cool he's a bad
[ __ ] I'll tell you what though
like you know obviously my girl's
Mexican is [ __ ] if you call someone else
the wrong Mexican or you're like oh
these Spanish I'm a man that ain't
awesome like narcos they put Spanish or
Venezuelan or you know certain and she's
like oh my god they're not even my
friend it was like it's close like you
tell right away
Oh totally it'd be like casting a guy
from the south as within the Austin like
we could pick it back to you that's not
Boston I'd be like casting summons out
for
England I mean it's a completely
different accent everything you know
it's like um has he directed anything
chin yeah but oh wow he directed Tropic
Thunder no I know he did kiss director
credits asked that's like you're saying
yeah Ben Stiller no Ben Stiller I know
he did I did the Cable Guy with Judd
Apatow he did a lot of right no he
didn't direct it reality bites
interesting yeah he did
flirting with disaster I think - I think
Zoolander - that's a tough one I didn't
see it cuz I liked his in there one I
heard it's a bummer
yeah that's it yeah Frost would you want
to direct or anything Brian I think so
maybe it's never really been it's never
been a huge thing for me no1 do it you
know man I mean um I don't know I kind
of lost my I like writing and I like
stand-up and I don't think anything
compares I mean what do you mean um
directing is a lot of work and a lot of
meticulous love at work and I don't and
and as far as doing like the acting that
Benicio del Toro I used to think that's
what I want to do I have so little
interest in it there's like a like a
drama dramatic little interest in
bringing a character to life in the
costume and and getting in character and
being in character and being around
other actors who are in character I have
I can't think of anything in a lot of
ways more torturous sorry to say though
like a change of opinion
I just love stand-up and I like comedy
and I just do you think that's as you've
been out that you know I'm saying like
you're not on the road cuz when you're
on the road like that that third or
fourth show you like Jesus Christ and I
can't wait to be home
it's it maybe it's like the love writing
in the challenge of stand-up and I don't
know I think because being on a film is
so tedious it's it's you're there all
day for so little acting too lot I just
don't I'm not feeling the most efficient
way to do it either but just the way
it's there's a manual process just the
way it's done you gotta get lighting the
way they issue the only way to do
lighting is to take your hands and
and fix your now filter and change the
lens and it's just a science and look at
it to the work usually use the stand-in
for it and you wait around and I just
don't want to do that I don't give a
[ __ ] I don't give a [ __ ] I don't I did
the process of making film is so
detailed with so many people not gonna
be the next bat
hey wait a minute hold on I didn't say
that yeah you can't just say that is
anybody listening to this something
that's Robin that's first I want to be
the Robin who would you like to play
what's your what's your role can tell
you you're a little lukewarm on acting
itself you like showbiz and stand-up and
comedy but yeah I mean if there's
something fun I'd be down to do it yeah
but as far as it being like my
profession 24/7 peanuts sad dude call me
sometime when you'll do a movie and
you're gonna be on there for two months
you give me a call I did that movie I
was on it set for four days like yeah
you know what my feet hurt ain't what I
want to do yeah yeah not my pants just
like me that's not what I want to do
you're just like me and then why I hate
to be away from I'm a homebody so you
want to put me in that situation or you
want you to have to Vancouver no not for
me now you want me to play Batman or
some fun role and it's a big deal well
I'll put up with it you will what
depends how long it is get them you're
serious I'm ship for three months yeah
that's what happens I wrote when Ryan
Ryan Philippi I was I'm seeing something
he came up with his kids and I was like
how you doing and he said I just
finished doing a movie and I was in
Namibia for nine months the desert
Africa because it was brutal and it was
a movie that I auditioned for I remember
and he's a great guy but I remember just
God that is not what I want to do you
know Ryan Philippi right I know of him I
I'm not trying to be my name is a
fascist
no don't why I funny how it's still
alive you know I'm not married and also
where the story's got kids it was it's
so funny though how he was the big deal
but yes how still have real intentions
yeah
he's still shy like somebody's in
limelight he stays away from any kind of
no he's definitely stay away from it no
you're right about that yeah he's in
shooter that he thought is he still
doing sometimes they go behind the
scenes you know yeah and I still doing
it but it's just funny how acting
there's no a lot of stuff go to the
career once Jen what's he been in that
series 16 the shooter yeah that's still
air he wasn't some great stuff yeah
good-looking dude oh yeah yeah he's in
crash does a good [ __ ] film yeah yeah
he's a he was really good Cruel
Intentions lost his big one still
dimepiece you ever see him around cute
guy still cutie still a cutie well
proportion not a big guy not a big guy
but one horse plot info dude yeah you're
too young for him right cat no I think
he's fine okay Wow
mercy I'm cruel intentions and I think I
thought he was a little too pretty in
that one yeah a little too pretty for me
he's a music he's a good guy and I'm
older I like yeah yeah been some big
movies have been doing for a hot minute
man oh yeah long time child actor on
daytime drama well left to live how
about if you're [ __ ] clean East who
had just been doing it for 89 years old
did you see the mule I didn't see how
riding I saw spider-man riding directing
like he's just gone hosing the music for
his movie sponsor that what falls deep
you didn't know he could impose music oh
so he's all I want to look it up uh you
ever see roses you ever see Pale Rider
whoa an auto fellow here that's from
music all his life oh he plays plays and
composes the music for his films Wow
okay I'm silo right any other questions
about one of the greatest movie stars
ever and directors ever and so he's been
acting since 1961 that's correct sir so
1960 to 2000
do you everybody should do themselves a
favor and go watch old movies like the
Eiger sanction or or Pale Rider hold
regatta no have you ever seen one hell
Rider yeah I'm watching The Outlaw Josey
Wales who send me a copy
what couple things we need no no do I'm
gonna watch it hey there's a link no
send me the link you dude
send me the link do you have a link for
it I'm late what we go back to is I'm
not seeing it furious and I'm gonna try
to stay calm Pale Rider pill writer and
the Outlaw Josey Wales
no scroll back up chin does first a lot
Jesse Wales Unforgiven juciano go to the
bottom you see let's go through it for a
sec hold on hold on
oh dude can you hold on do you have a
copy of ledger with Dirty Harry no let's
let's start with I keep going up please
so start with starring the dust 1950 be
gone please keep going but we can pass
all this stuff because the Fistful of
Dollars phenomenal I mean the good the
parent the good dude we're all hi good
the bad and the ugly the good the bad
the ugly are you kidding no I hang them
high hold on keep going I'll tell you
what for my money doesn't get better
than paint your wagon write this down
you guys Dirty Harry a world only
started everything High Plains Drifter
stop who's he played the stranger High
Plains Drifter dude these were the
ultimate the ultimate the ultimate
[ __ ] westerns and the ice and white
don't be scared tonight the IAR don't
although Josey Wales in the Eiger
sanction they should tell him shut up
right now tell him bro dude 1984 tight
rope any [ __ ] great religions great
movie let's go bro
hey I don't have to beat you up in the
name of Clint Eastwood dude I'm sorry I
apologize no all you got to do dude
Simulink Simulink expected
Simulink i'm dude all you got to do is
send me a link to clint eastwood's old
movies dude I swear to God do it how old
all right send me a link now listen up
this is [ __ ] sucking right there now
where you gonna go get the [ __ ] off me
all right sake let me switch sucks
say it say it
alright see okay you left me no choice
that's not right I wanna apologize you
can't put me in it it's gonna get in the
way of my boxing okay apologize to all
the viewers oh sorry guys I just get
pissed off a man quit you know bro how'd
you know Jay did things hurt hey those
look cool I've never seen him yeah good
man you're out of breath bro you're out
not in shape for me too I'm good brother
put me in a [ __ ] ankle lock which I
gave to you yeah isn't the [ __ ] gonna
start greasing my [ __ ] foot and ankle
is in the name of Clan bro all I said
was send me a link and you couldn't back
it up and piss me off
heartbreak ridge the gauntlet 1977 great
movies go watch his old Louise do me a
favor for a second to him do that all I
want you to do is bring up dude hi guy
Plains Drifter and the scene where for
the first time the bullies the bad guys
oh my god for my money doesn't get any
better now listen we're gonna bring this
up go and take a heart
now you said boy bro all right sorry
dude baby
no more I'm sorry ah there it is a
saloon same punch the horse said that
fluency might be good let's see the
saloon scene or or the whipping revenge
one or the other
look at that step god it's good god that
acting is good hold on that's set like
so legit Oh some great actors that's a
great character actress back my bare
flesh guys give him that he was a great
cowboy though yeah it was just the
sounds of the horses footsteps don't
match up at all but let's not worry
about this listen to it got a train look
I'm looking at the stranger I think it's
gonna be this the whole way through it
out just him riding to town leaders
stupid [ __ ] stupid [ __ ]
now he's thinking he always played these
characters that just came in and didn't
say that's actors
I'll tell i watch this I go I can't do
that
i watch this I go I can't do that so
he's just saying nothing and just riding
on the horse he's riding tight it's too
much man it's might not have been the
best scene this is Helen it is great the
way they would like who is this guy I
will film this right now my iPhone ah I
just love the sound of the Train
oh god those sets like so legit dude oh
there's the saloon there's the boys
these bad guys oh there's the bowl
[ __ ] alert yeah here are the bad guys
dude look at that okay right back bro
yeah ground get into that great looking
dude looking dude he looked right back
here there was the Clint scowl [ __ ]
[ __ ] out cuz that's a Clint scowl
mmm-hmm mean so he walked by and these
guys in do you think place would [ __ ]
all the girls back there hot there's no
question I think he's got about 27 kids
he does and and he didn't like see how
that guy with that horse he does not
like that he doesn't like when you whip
a horse okay
you got to know that this scene fires me
up bro I find inspiring out Wednesday
some I find dysentery it's about two and
[ __ ] you avatar - dude I'll take this
how about that scarf around his neck oh
[ __ ] - listen I like the jacket weren't
Spurs probably go Spurs oh [ __ ]
then dude he's walkin out well he's
walking over he's no no oh they're all
deaf in this town
oh I've seen this one yeah they don't
talk yeah they're all deaf now yeah yeah
I know I've seen this what
country-western look that's good they're
all dad have some patience because
really old they're all deaf right here's
the storm oh it's actually scary this up
this is a [ __ ] watch this yeah no one
says anything tall I share the most of
my money that's big
okay you know what I like about these
moves to the diversity is a peaceful I
gotta watch this I you know why bro
[ __ ] man [ __ ] it's not equal
these back then [ __ ]
oh you look at this second hole Ambrose
sounds about to pop off oh that's how I
do it
who's that sexy cowboy in there right
huh mr. steal your girl look at him just
pulled up with not those [ __ ] dude you
see him look up slow the snarl bro
always had that smile check out that
dumb ass
sike heard about be a bunch of guns
things here he would whisper but let us
turn yellow fashion right stop a chin so
we don't know we gotta see the gun fight
we don't have to play this whole thing
maybe we can just get an edit I don't
know how long is this whole bit bit I
was it oh wow
nobody is a big deal dude can I see the
comments on that one just is there any
funny comments it's probably all over
people like um Clint was born a few
months after my dad my dad's a cowboy
who grew Kalin wrench don't give a [ __ ]
a great scene great actor all his movies
are great that's all positive for him
well he's that yeah he was the great
soft it also you like getting the
younger audience we're gonna he was also
the great western I mean he made great
westerns because they were real stories
that horse sounds like real train preach
dude preach music lover nine three six
what can suck my dick
Wow who said that keep which is sad to
be gun I don't see it
no one said that Clint Eastwood [ __ ]
my mom she's good actor no at underscore
two seven nine Strauss reading these
things it's all live ladies would sucked
my dick yeah surprise spoiler okay a
[ __ ] mark underscore Laurent this is
ridiculous do Clint Eastwood swallowed
my Jill no no this is a lie you're
making this dog these are these Kyle I
don't see any of it claims would would
have been working construction in LA and
none of us would have ever heard of him
if he couldn't ride a horse it's hard to
look like a stud strolling up center of
town yes he [ __ ] my mom twice Jesus
well that's March 7 goat it might be
true
alright well you can you can change it
now how's filmed in California it says
let's go to some current events man yeah
man let's get off its nuts
yeah so just a little update to the fake
moon landing story that we did last week
the Golden State Warriors played
Sacramento Kings and while they were in
the stadium the Kings played video of
the moon-landing Patrol them loose and
Steph Curry came out and said that he
was joking during the podcast and
someone from NASA offered him along with
all the guys a tour of NASA to show that
educator yeah to educate him and he said
he'd love to go that's the only thing I
think the Sacramento Kings have done
right this season but that's good that's
hilarious
whose announcement zero-energy number 30
Stephanie Curry the head coach of the
Warriors deep that's pretty funny good
for them dude damn good what else we got
man there you go
so Pete Davidson posted something up on
Instagram saying that he didn't want to
be here anymore and he shortly after
deleted the post along with his entire
Instagram account and a lot of people
reached out I reach out to my tech Samia
ariana grande actually flew out after
finding out about the thing that he
posted up went to Saturday Night Live
and was waiting for him downstairs yeah
he showed up for her Saturday Night Live
very shortly just to introduce Miley but
he wasn't in the show is he is he had a
history of depression or something yeah
here's a line personality disorder as
well that's horrible man oh hope he's
all right
he's just saying like I told you I don't
wanna be here anymore so don't say I
didn't warn you stuff like that could be
a cry for help too you know it's like
definitely a cry for a ride for help you
need a lot of help man so it's a [ __ ]
bummer
here's where it got our boy Rapoport
just just tone-deaf to certain
situations like he made fun of Kanye who
talked about mental disorders and then
Pete Davidson and he just roast him I
think I think rapper out there do an
apology because his bad man
hmm well yeah there you go Nicki Minaj
got it right because y'all did the same
thing to Mack mill until he died so
strange how people they know these guys
have so here's his mexico's I really
don't want to be on this earth anymore
I'm doing my best to stay here for you
but I actually don't know how much
longer I can last all I've ever tried to
do was help people just remember I told
you sure any put that on Instagram yeah
then he took it down it's just so
strange that people [ __ ] they know he
suffers some stuff and they still go at
him I can't have a person you have to be
man I know I don't know much about him
what else you got so Kanye went on
another tweet tirade
he's been according to him off his meds
for the last six months and during that
time he tweet a bunch of things about
him and Drake coming after his family a
whole spiel of things and he talked
about mental health as well he's
currently off of his meds to work on his
next album he says I can't write a good
album with hit while being on his meds
and being healthy and that's why he's
back on Twitter and you guys saw this
Joe Rogan said that he wanted to have
them on the show to talk about menthols
could there be a better platform for him
I know they're like oh you're just
saying cuz Joe is your boy no think
about this Joe's not affiliated with any
big media outlet so Connie can go on
there he can go on there for an hour you
go on there for two hours you go on
there for three hours and Joe has no
bias there's nothing you just gonna let
him air out whatever he wants
name a better platform I think I agree
go name about a name a bigger platform
go I agree
Connie can go on The Tonight Show he go
on Jimmy Fallon he'd gone Stephen
Colbert you go on CNN named Amy show
Annie show and nothing's bigger than joe
rogan show and not only that you get
through a public platform in three hours
for a room but you don't have to do
three you do an hour down 30 doesn't
matter there's no agenda you go on there
talk about your shoes the impact
Jill's not gonna press yummy yeah Joe
has no agenda there's nothing he just
talks I don't know why he wouldn't do it
notice how he says it happy happy to
talk to you it's not an interview you
know see what happens though yeah what
else yet so an actor on the Andy Mac
show which is a Disney show got arrested
recently for trying to hook up with a 13
year old girl or a girl that he thought
was 13 online it was a part of a sting
operation catfish I mean he got they see
her chance and Chris Hansen I'll take a
seat
Wow and he was on a Disney show
he's on a Disney show she's playing the
Grand pub this little girl Jesus and
Disney issued a message right away after
this happening saying that he was
released and that in everybody's best
interest you will no longer be on the
show they have no affiliation with him
because it's Disney such a family friend
how did you know that that she was 13 it
was from dating a yeah play booty hole
yeah there's a thirst mail homeboy
Christ he sent images of himself before
taking a ride-sharing vehicle with
intent to median Wow
what is he thinking anyway what are you
doing this is Salt Lake City mm-hmm what
a weird dude look at him what else you
got
Wow a guy's super [ __ ] see ya tough to
get job at Disney after that man uh yeah
a job anywhere that all right
well as you know everyone's been tagging
us have you started showing this know
the why dead guy yeah so you know
there's a yeah so they paired up yeah
they're all over the yeah like Instagram
worldstar now they're rappers hit it
chin they're ready cap really
capitalizing on their recent
oh I'm pausing for a second who would
you rather be
yeah good picnic you'd rather be
thinking if you want thick neck yeah
yeah you gotta be thick neck yeah yeah
don't be long yeah daddy long neck you
don't want that
all right care next up no girls coming
after them oh wow Walters Tong dude how
much money that girl get paid
look at that [ __ ] tongue a girl's
hottest [ __ ] face all she does keep
licking them though that's her thing
that's now Brian ray you and I could rap
better right now do they have a
disability
that girl is I'm not much traffic I
don't notice these stupid now I'm not
mad at her at all no neither one oldest
longneck daddy must be 18 was it of acne
so skinny
I feel like girl how much they paid act
like this [ __ ] in this though and
they feel miss at the mall apparently
the widen it's not comfortable in camera
he's not kind of a modest kid probably
she's deliver proven yeah but to craze
about the long that kids but she is damn
damn long neck okay how long do you
think they're fameless' but I call high
art don't you think they're faint just
ended buddy never started what else you
get just then I'm hoping you saw this
Brennan Steven Smith I didn't I use to
watch First Take so he was naming off
different people that weren't even
playing talking about a game I'll I'll
just show you right now and the thing is
look at look at the other panelists
leave that Abruzzi like what the [ __ ]
solitaire Bruce yeah I like all of them
I liked all of me I missed every night
all right this matchup right here
Beckett I'm sorry Spencer where is out
oh yes yes yes I forgot I'm sorry
do it yeah absolutely he is out but I'm
thinking Tyreke he'll I'm thinking
Patrick mahomes I'm also looking at the
San Diego Chargers on offense and I'm
thinking about hunting Reed and the way
that he's played this year as effective
as he's been he's going up against there
Johnson and I got his way I'm at with
all of this at the end of the day I'm
looking at Patrick the halls I'm looking
at so you can see the list of stuff he
had wrong here so Spencer was out any
other has a great scene according to him
Derek Johnson not in yeah okay dear
John's used to be a famous Chiefs
linebacker though so yeah he just
doesn't fall out huh
yeah that's embarrassing well there it
says returned Spencer were foot injury
generaiiy brewskis face yes i ended
he's like [ __ ] it was brewski
does he have any some mornin Arizona
Mexican I think Tedy Bruschi Italian is
that right Clayton Arizona hey watch out
we play for like at least ten years hot
second Russia Russia the Italian
grandmother was Batali really yep you
know ah time I Filipino son ah alright
you go very good I he's a stud man super
stud yep alright what else you got and
then funny though this is um Jon Gruden
reply drama you can see here I don't
know these names so but he goes talk to
you the team we've got to get ready for
hilarious and Rossum yeah what fozzy
Curtis down the middle we got to get Tim
Brown and all receivers ready to play
Tim Brown retired I mean forever ago
that's hilarious he really did that yeah
that's how I heard that telling us what
else alright this a human heart was left
on a Southwest flight and ninety minutes
into the flight they found out and it
had to turn around and go back because
it was waiting yeah
so luckily if it was the actual heart
heart it would have been a loss but
they're just going for the valves which
lasted because there's only a certain
amount of time again you could stay
fresh or whatever hold on why are we
flying a human heart that's another
weird thing it's
weird thing cuz people handle fast what
sir it's fast you can you can't take it
by horse and buggy anymore well I felt
well why don't you want more expensive
right I mean a private jet ups then we
get first class I mean there's so many
Southwest doesn't get anybody on time
little on a hard on time but it's still
mysterious there's like a lot of
mysterious things about this why but it
so the reason why I was left off was
because someone forgot it because a
courier supposed to pick it up and the
courier just didn't pick it up but
doesn't give you a lot of details all
himself who left it there huh that's so
strange from Southwest some so it means
maybe a private courier decided to fly
Southwest well they have the plane lands
the courage was to grab that package but
for some reason that didn't happen whole
thing's weird yeah it's very well sure
if I need a heart transplant don't you
Southwest to get it to me this swimmer
who was swimming on her own and then saw
orcas next to her that she thought were
dolphins at first orcas are not yeah
that's really nice look how closely gets
her don't say great weight though three
of them likely an adult's a juvenile and
a calf swimming around Judy allowed just
virtually nipping at her toes they're
scary
Judy Johnson's lived in high for years
normally makes up with friends for a
morning swim when nobody else turned up
I thought well it's just me also on the
beach Ozzy tourists Dylan Bray sure he
was shocked when he saw Judy blindly
swimming towards the killer whales I've
seen that trainers get harmed in
captivity but in the wild I didn't know
what to expect didn't know what was
gonna have interpreter here address is
so good I was actually caught this
luckily at the far end of the beach Judy
got out so cool although imagine thought
should seal them to get flipper went
yeah so they kill they they've never had
there's never been one recorded instance
of an Oregon in the wild ever biting or
hurting human brothers
that knowing blackfish no no no no
though there is and all right there in
the wild where'd you read that search in
garnet YouTube you talking about when it
grabs the lady by the [ __ ] ankle why
that what is that - in SeaWorld nope not
in real now this is real no but not not
in the wild that's we ever been in some
soup Orca attack human wild sorry sir
yeah I think this is just no never
happen
yeah know that I'm telling you there
there's a there's a there's a lady she
got another one where pulled under in
SeaWorld
no must see Costa Rica oh the orcas kill
the dolphins oh my god they eat dolphins
I forgot about that yeah no that's not
oh I'm telling you there's a video this
lady swimming that grabs her by the foot
and goes so that was maybe he's just
playing though no yeah but that's
they've never it's never as never
attacked them only one person has ever
been injured in wild Orca yeah four
people have been killed in captivity
only captivity or a diver and New
Zealand below the source and service for
more than 40 seconds earlier this month
that's the one that you must be talking
yep doesn't attack many people who work
with water because they're not so sure
the thing is just playing yeah because
if it wanted to kill you forget it even
that one that was the only saw was like
nipping at her but bottom line feet so
it'd be scary though if you know oh yeah
I mean they're they're savage they laugh
at great whites you what do you got you
got a great white oh good I'm gonna eat
you now they needs it spleen out the
liver first a lot of great whites are
just missing their livers yeah cuz it
loves the taste of the really the
nutrients so ever is it like that and
rips the liver out [ __ ] that's amazing
according the story the well never
actually touched the guy just grab this
flipper I guess well yeah there you go
pulled him under yeah that's really
interesting what else you got man I got
this do you remember this story a wall
about a while ago or the Indian dude on
a plane we're not sitting next to his
wife and started following the girl next
to him while she was sleeping
no I forget this one so this is what oh
definitely no do you remember that he
looks like the kind of guy that would
fondle I would not fall asleep like that
[ __ ] got a dick yeah so he was not a
victim we saw it she was asleep at the
time she was trying to find her shirt
and trousers unbuttoned his hands were
in her trousers she said that she said
that she woke up to him inside her his
fingers inside her Wow okay so what
happens here chin jail for nine years
nine years interesting no weird dude
well I I think that's the kind of guy
who's a rapist
sorry I don't think that's know you know
yeah bad man
agree and he's a rapist so the longer
he's in jail the better to me like III
don't believe that that's when you do
something little like that you do
something big you know that's brazen
it's a junior Jimmy Burke was on a plane
on train one time and he was getting off
in the this this dude this girl was
sitting there reading and the guy
reached out grabbed her tits and then
she went whoo like that and then he got
off the train
so Jimmy [ __ ] Jimmy can't have it
Jimmy follows him across the street he
get something goes I just he had a
rolled-up magazine he goes hey man so
you grab that girl's tits huh it was
good the guy goes oh yeah well and Jimmy
grabbed him by the arm and he goes hey
man let's take a walk and he goes what
and he started hitting him on top of the
head with the newspaper all the way
across the street what right there and
then he waits for the guy went into work
he was a it was a wedding to work as a
waiter and he went and told the boss
what he did [ __ ] all right I guess this
is the last one
have you seen this kid no I'll just play
for you it's interesting because you're
being no a so you're in a note list
you're not because you're not because
you ain't paying goods again father
christmas rubs brung me last night when
I was at work I said you better tell
Jackson to start being a good boy or
he's gonna stay on the naughty list then
he won't I get no presents for Christmas
that's what you said to me so you got to
start being a good boy you're just silly
man you're on the naughty list mayor
won't it be a good book that was it [ __ ]
you too she'll meet up with mr. cute
I'll just be receive my my nephew was
their age I used to [ __ ] let me dress
like Batman I'd be like you're not
Batman because yes I am like alright
hold on stand there let me see you it's
10 I go yeah Batman yes he's getting
smarter forget him he says let's build
up you want that he's so cute man stupid
I'm not I'm not on the nine yes is that
it that's it
all he's thinking about is presence that
was good man yeah is that it be that's
it buddy thanks man man what Africa when
you leave well not till Friday
you leave Friday in South Africa I'll
bring you a night you want them bring
you back something
you want me to poach something for you
bring your back in I Oh bring me back
some of those guys from the island
mm-hmm they're in the Bay of Bengal no
educator on great anywhere near there
I'm going to sow that oh I'm sorry baby
I was in Thailand India thank you sir
but bring bring back another when are
you gonna be in Pasadena you're gonna be
at the past a nice house December 28th
I'm there next weekend dude me and some
friends maybe Andrew Santino made some
other funnier dudes in me December 28th
29th then I'm in Edmonton January 10th
through the 12th Edmonton Canada all
rearing up for San Diego January 19
Bryan Callen a special guests are opened
up for me January 19th Spreckels Theatre
200 tickets left for both shows that
[ __ ] almost sold out Spreckels
Theatre San Diego t5k calm get them
bride anything else before you go to
Africa what's happening it's just uh
it's a video ah that's I gotta get out
of this for the fire kid we're out